what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the mandatory evacuation of the New York
comedy club that took place last week
while Mark Norman was on stage has only
gotten more mysterious since the
original video leaked online which first
showed a seemingly intoxicated Stranger
in an orange hat wandering on stage for
a few seconds before being dragged off
by security a woman located on the left
side of the screen runs after the man
and Mark Norman is left on stage
slightly stunned but still throwing out
Zinger like a pro trying to keep the
situation as light as possible oh jeez
hey how are what we got a migr here hey
what's going on oh jeez I really froze
there I went Mitch McConnell up to this
point nothing too far out of the
ordinary has even occurred as it's not
that rare for a comedy show to have to
remove an audience member for doing
something stupid but where things get
very strange however is immediately
after this Mark himself was then told to
get off stage without a chance to give
any sort of explanation which left the
crowd in a state of confusion and panic
until this announcement was made guys
everything's fine um we just had a
momentary Interruption
um uh just stay get up get out the the
taping um can we get out or what the
camera yeah I'm one of the producers of
the show um yeah we just need everybody
to get out
please nice and slow nice and slow
everything's fine but excuse me got any
photos or video the two producers who
took the mic after Mark was escorted out
of the building not only forgot to
explain to the paying customers why
their headliner just left midow but also
failed to ensure the audience of their
safety and displayed a level of fear and
confusion that only added to the tension
oh my God okay it's happening everybody
stay calm what's the procedure everyone
what's the procedure stay
calm calm down there have been many
theories shared online about what this
disruption possibly could have been
about from a standard bomb threat to the
theory that the man in the orange hat
was running to a public place to avoid a
Hitman or even people who were convinced
that this was a legitimate terrorist
attack that was actively being
investigated by the FBI there's been
thousands of possible explanations
thrown out there for what might be
behind this disturbance but the real
answer is much much stupider than anyone
could have predicted for the first 24
hours after this video leaked the only
information anyone was provided with
came from Mark Norman's Instagram story
where it was said that his team is
looking into it the following afternoon
New York comedy club finally released an
official statement where they said quote
we've received a handful of inquiries
regarding a viral clip of our club being
evacuated last night first and foremost
nobody was harmed or injured the
disruption was part of a filming by the
producers that rented out our venue for
the night so since this took on a bit of
a wild narrative if you were in
attendance for the taping we'd love to
host you for an actual show for free
please email us at info@ New York comedy
club club.com this news was then
confirmed by Mark Norman's story which
read no one was harmed or injured during
my performance last night at New York
comedy club the disruption was part of a
planed surprise activity by show
producers I had no prior knowledge that
this was going to happen it turns out
this plan surprise during Mark's show
was one of three events to be disrupted
that night in New York City all a part
of an attempt at viral Gorilla Marketing
by a new Amazon Prime show about spies
called We're bleeping out the name of
the show and the name of the production
company because I personally don't want
to be involved in helping this campaign
go viral but I'm sure you could look it
up if you're actually interested as we
were saying the lead actor of the show
Donald Glover also reposted videos from
each of the three incidents on his
Instagram Story one of which was a fake
Smash and grab at a local Art Exhibit
which just like this fake bomb threat
situation seems like more of a blatant
crime than a publicity stunt the third
incident took place on the Jumbotron
during a Nets game when two furries that
were sitting Courtside started making
out which again might as well just be
considered breaking the
[Music]
law even after some of these pieces were
put together there still seemed to be
some confusion as to how this all got
organized in the first place and who
knew what was going to happen luckily
for us Mark Norman was just on the most
recent episode of legion of skanks where
they happened to have him hooked up to a
lie detector what happened at the New
York comedy club can you talk about it I
signed an NDA but here's what happened
so go dixel out now no basically uh they
they set up a show and they're like you
do a 45 minute set and something crazy
is going to happen we're not going to
tell you what and I was like all right
I'll just I'll do a set and then a guy
walked on stage and I ripped on it and
that was it that was it so you knew
somebody was something was going to
happen I something but they didn't tell
me what I figured it'd be like a crow
work thing they tell you why uh they're
trying to go viral and build Buzz for an
internet company now knowing that this
was all part of a pre-planned marketing
stunt is not only annoying but but also
leaves a lot of unanswered questions in
my book for example if the producers
rented out the comedy club like they
said in the official statement does that
mean that the owners of the club knew
this was going to happen and if so why
would they allow this to go on during a
show and not even explain it to
potentially terrified customers it's
also interesting to think back on that
first lady who took the mic who was
quaking in her boots trying to form any
sort of sentence if she knew what was
going on then that's the greatest acting
performance of all time but purposely
panicking on stage while telling people
to evacuate kind of seems like it should
be against the law so quite frankly I
still don't know what to think about
this girl we just had a
momentary Interruption um uh just stay
get up get out the the taping this
entire thing has to feel a little weird
from Mark Norman's point of view I
assume he wouldn't want to be associated
with something like disrupting a live
comedy show but there's a reason these
producers chose a bigname comic like
Norman to be their Mark if the
campaign's end goal was to generate
headlines including a notable comedian
with high SEO results would be a must so
they said all right you'll do a show
something weird is going to happen but
we don't want to tell you what and then
you just react to it I was like that
doesn't sound like my thing and they
were like here's how much money you'll
be making and I was like do you need to
tase
me I'll wear black face whatever you
want I'm in you know Mark were you paid
were you paid a lot more money no no
money was involved no
money there's my first question let's
see if that lit up or
not it's easy to feel bad for the people
in the audience that night who were
basically pranked by Amazon Prime into
thinking they might die but it's also
worth mentioning that not watching this
show would be a great way to curb stupid
like this from happening again this
bizarre Mark Norman story is just one of
the dozens of Comedy current events
happening right now 2024 is off to an
insane start and if you want to stay up
to date with all your favorite comedians
be sure to subscribe to joke world right
now we're kind of like sports center but
instead of Sports we talk about comedy
so I did a show and a guy walked on
stage and that was about it I I didn't
know what to do I was like oh this is
crazy I tried to make a joke hey is this
where we're putting the migrants hey all
right uh yada yada JW tunnel whatever
and uh and then the guy the security
guard goes come on off come on off stage
and I walked off stage and then I left
some lady was filming on her phone and
then the front row and she just got the
last of it so the whole thing's like
what the hell happened you got pulled
off stage holy thanks for watching
did it feel good though Mark in a sense
of like the outpouring of people like
like right before I was going to text
you I heard like I kind of got it and
saw I was like oh it's not like a real
thing yeah yeah everybody's like was
this a Chappelle thing was this a Chris
Rock slap I was like it's more of a
Jesse Smet
but at joke
World let it J
world and the world is
wld that's a great YouTube channel joke
World check it out